oi boa noite será o último sempre um
desafio né mas vamos caminhar juntos
aqui vou falar um pouquinho sobre essa
questão tensa do tal do irmão center
design na verdade a gente tá indo para
uma sociedade onde o ser humano retoma
tudo aquilo que ele perdeu ao longo do
tempo tentando se parecer com uma
máquina obsoleta negócio impressionante
que você arrumando gostou de parecer com
máquina ele matou o longo ao longo do
tempo tudo aquilo que eram suas
expressões humanas para dar espaço para
uma máquina obsoleto o tempo quando a
gente fala do futuro do trabalho é esse
mesmo o futuro é trabalho não é emprego
vamos viver tempos em que a gente já não
quer mais emprego mas quer morrer de
trabalhar você pode ter um monte de
opções as pessoas ficam tão viciadas
naquelas rotinas intermináveis naquelas
empresa chatérrima monolíticas sem
criatividade executando tarefa de
máquina cheia de roteiro solteiro
solteiro solteiro
oi e a gente sempre tá lindo competindo
com outro buscando uma promoçãozinha se
ela vier esse mundo não tem o menor
sentido porque a gente tá vendo que cada
vez mais aquele que chega sobre a gente
no século 21 vem muito turbo sobre a
gente porque aceleração do ritmo de
mudanças é tudo que a gente tem a gente
vai falar assim a inovação é uma coisa
aqui agora aconteceu não a inovação ela
é um requerimento de um movimento
exponencial que surgem sobre a gente
desde o tempo do neandertal não tem nada
de novo a tecnologia como base ela dobra
ou sobre ela mesma a cada dois anos e o
custo cai pela metade o que acontece com
essa curva exponencial e ela ficou
visível para os humanos nos anos de 1950
a partir disso se agravou até os anos 90
com a chegada da internet quando você
ganha então o grande a grande
possibilidade de atravessar mais um
portal para você ganhar duas dimensões
então passamos a ser um ser híbrido nós
somos cyber híbridos
e nós temos parte da nossa vida tá no tá
no site despacho parte da nossa vida tá
aqui no terreno físico é preciso de
alguma maneira que só uma notícia isso
para em algum tempo não a gente como
estudante de futuro né como somos eu sou
um da revista digital e em base eu sou
uma profissão do futuro no presente a
gente olha até 2050 olha até 2090 olha
até 3050 não tem nada nos algoritmos que
digam que isso vai acabar um tempo o
tanto que a gente liga liga ao longo de
toda a nossa jornada agentes ética que
não acaba mais cirurgias robóticas
comida impressa você vai ter a
reprodução do genoma se você ficar
doente ou reforma você tão simplesmente
ditando o seu genoma orelhas impressos a
gente levar o sangue empréstimo a nossa
acabou de anunciar que começa agora uma
nova tecnologia que tira a comida de
gases de efeito estufa fazendo
fotossíntese não é completamente
artificial vamos comer um monte de coisa
que a gente não reconhece carne empresa
você comeria uma picanha de um bico que
não existe
e vamos começar a fazer isso qual o
sonho ou talvez das vacas morar em todas
na índia né porque vamos comer carne que
não precisa matar mais o bicho aí eu
fico pensando nos veganos eles voltarem
vou comer carne
as perguntas que não acabam mais porque
a tecnologia tem o poder de subverter
absolutamente tudo porque ela muda
radicalmente a sociedade ela muda
radicalmente as economias que estão no
entorno o tempo quando a gente olha tudo
isso nosso presente e já é bastante
inseto porque a gente vê tudo isso
chegando o que tá acontecendo com o
nosso futuro o que que é completamente
complexo é que tudo aquilo que a gente
imaginava que era uma grande utopia lá
na frente a utopia tá virando distopia o
que acontece quando você tem um filme de
ficção você achava lindo nossa que coisa
legal quero viver nisso mas ninguém
nunca percebeu que um filme de ficção
seja ele qual for ao longo de todo o
tempo não tem ninguém almoçando e
jantando já perceberam isso então não
era para humanos agora o que acontece o
futuro chega sobre a gente mas muito
violentamente batendo no nariz da gente
todo tempo porque ser humano curto ou
para vista dá sentido à sua vida na
próxima meia hora trabalha intensamente
pelo agora e esquece que o que acontece
no futuro futuro ele pode ser pra
e aí dentro do futuro previsível você
pode além de tudo escolher o seu futuro
preferível então de alguma maneira o teu
futuro né é preferível você vai ter e
você pode começar a modelar ele a partir
de agora então quando você tem os teus
modelos preferíveis você começa a
trabalhar com um pouquinho mais de calma
então o que acontece as pessoas tão
desesperada porque acho que até vigência
artificial vai roubar os empregos delas
não inteligência artificial não cobra
emprego de ninguém a inteligência
artificial a sua rotina o grande
problema é que você transformou sua vida
numa rotina interminável a inteligência
artificial vai roubar de você tudo isso
não claro que não ela já robô
bom e você preocupado que vai perder o
emprego e eu continuo na minha jornada
lidando com gente é um negócio
impressionante que eu me dá nos nervos
isso que ela fala assim não não quero
nem imaginar esse mundo porque puxa a
tecnologia como a gente tá falando ali a
gente algum algoritmo ali que é
progresso humano versus tempo se o
algoritmo não se modificar vamos poder
em 40 anos vive há 500 anos você quer
dizer 500 anos
oh alô
oi e aí eu perguntei as pessoas olham
para mim falar assim não pelo amor de
deus não quero viver 500 anos vou passar
500 anos pagando o boleto ser humano é
problema passa uma vida inteira né é
apagando velinhas de aniversário já
viram que a coisa mais estúpida que a
gente faz porque na resgate toda vez que
você faz aniversário alguém chega com um
bolo tem uma vela o que que você faz vai
lá e só para cada vez mais está fazendo
um pedaço seu e você ainda canta para
isso uma coisa estúpida estúpida
estúpida estúpida quando você pode viver
para sempre ninguém quer ai não não
quero ai que coisa atenção vou ver para
serem para fazer o quê da minha vida o
marquito em que é um autor maravilhoso
ele tem uma frase que eu adoro e fala
assim só existe na sua vida de verdade
dois dias muito importantes o dia que
você nasce e o dia que finalmente você
entende por que nasceu a gente só
comemore primeiro vou ter começar a
comemorar o segundo a menos que você
tenha caído da nave-mãe e suaviza tá
vendo que você tá fazendo aqui a gente
não vai conseguir enxergar muito
claramente né que como meu colega
anterior falou a questão do propósito
quem
o que tu faz tudo de propósito quem não
tem propósito faz tudo por acaso isso
hoje vai fazer uma diferença que você
não tem noção para dar o erro duradouro
para gente portanto nosso futuro e
depois você extremamente confuso porque
a gente tá conta outra vista e as
pessoas não conseguem imaginar que
futuro vai ser esse para elas mesmas
porque ela só pensam no presente quando
você vai nas empresas que é o meu ângulo
nossa é uma loucura aquilo porque elas
estão na que se engalfinhando naquele
jogo né competitivos e entrego as em
ponto de chegada sem nada se batendo se
matando não faz mais sentido isso a
gente foi para o mundo colaborativo como
a gente nunca viu e as pessoas continuam
competindo entre elas não faz sentido
gamorrean tem um super filósofo
contemporâneo ele fala que o antigo
universo além de tudo ele controlava e
ele deste lava o tempo hoje o novo
universo elevado pelo tempo eu tava
brincando agora pouco falando que eu não
tenho a menor saudade da minha infância
porque isso faz muito tempo foi antes da
revolução russa né é onde eu
e eu morava três anos para passar eu não
tinha uma console de videogame não tinha
streaming de vídeo eu não tinha internet
para brigar eu não ia para o facebook o
que existia porque a gente podia ir para
lá para brigar não tinha nada disso um
tédio sem fim o que acontece hoje que o
tempo ele é um grande ralo que puxa você
para baixo porque na realidade o tempo
ele tá ficando cada vez mais algoz de
todos nós então uma das grandes luxos do
futuro será exatamente o que é um
silêncio a privacidade o tempo e o
offline esquece então assim até
movimento lá não quero saber eu vou me
trancar né vou viver num veleiro vou
viver num veleiro não a gente não
aguenta a nossa cabeça que assim que tá
acontecendo lá que que tá acontecendo lá
tem que dá tempo de alguma coisa nosso
cérebro é completamente voltado para
isso e vamos falar que das coisas do bem
não das coisas do mal né do eles versus
nós e tudo isso que acontece do grande
batimento das redes que não tinham uma
perda de tempo gigante o lapso do tempo
o que que é isso o nosso tempo de ficar
cada vez mais urgente ele fica a casa
mesmo cada vez mais
a cada vez mais significativo e a gente
não sabe o que faz com ele portanto tudo
saiu do lugar ao mesmo tempo e quando a
gente olha que é que ele tá todo mundo
vuca né que a gente já brinca de dizer
que é uma muvuca completa não é multa é
muvuca né porque levou lá tio ele
sugestão muitas flutuações mudanças
bruscas inesperadas incerto a gente
mudanças né instabilidade informações
que não estão disponíveis explosão
gigante desse mundo complexo que é
justamente a explosão de variáveis que
estão efeito esmagador pelo ser humano
nosso cérebro não é feito bairro design
para aguentar isso e além de tudo ali
umbigo porque eu tenho muito múltiplos
fatores de causa e efeito você imagina o
que que faz um ser humano no mundo de
louco que é isso aqui e todo mundo
trabalhando para poder dar algum
significado ou todo mundo trabalhando
para poder manter as aparências que tá
tudo legal não está esse mundo leva a
gente alguma coisa que é muito diferente
do que a gente está acostumado né então
a gente vive num mundo cada vez mais
conectado com muita tecnologia mas
também como uma sociedade
e a gente eu tive também uma velocidade
estonteante até a gente que trabalha com
isso levar susto toda hora de ver assim
como assim a velocidade tá muito grande
sobre nós muito grande não tem como
parar isso né em composições né em forma
de conexões completamente caótica cirrê
significantes o que acontece que a
tecnologia tem o poder de mudar o
significado das coisas ser humano é ser
escravo do passado da muita né canja
para o próprio status quo fica mantendo
espaço quando eu deveria tá quebrando a
lógica corrente para eu poder ser um
pouquinho mais hacker não sei um cara
mais né viciado no futuro de sábado
passado tentando re-significar o futuro
um presente que eu não compreendo né
então o pensamento sistêmico é básico
para que a gente hoje possa ver as
interconexões para gente ganhar
diferentes perspectivas quando a gente
viu o longo do tempo todas as revoluções
industriais tinha a primeira linha
chegada do vapor da água segundo a
chegada da eletricidade a terceira
internet anos 90 a quarta revolução 2012
é bem com sistemas cyber livre dos
homens as máquinas já começam a fazer
coisas sozinhas é sozinhas as pessoas
pensam que a gente programa as máquinas
já temos robôs modulares auto
configurável os robôs se montam para
determinada tarefa e ainda se alta
configuram e o ser humano tá aonde nisso
e tomando rivotril
e o que que tá chegando sobre a gente a
quinta revolução industrial que a
chegada em menos de 40 anos da
inteligência artificial super
inteligente onde você vai ter máquinas
que serão melhor do que muitas mentes
humanas em todos os campos da atividade
científica era uma coisa de maluco que
tá vendo pela frente estamos ontem
perdidos na terceira revolução
industrial dando ordem para aquela
porcaria daquele excel que você não vivo
sem todo mundo dando ordem para
maquininha gente as máquinas já fazem
sozinhos dá para você entender que você
é ridículo perdendo tempo na frente a um
computador que não tem mais o menor
sentido larga as máquinas fazer elas
podem pensar hoje já existentes 200
petaflops 200 petaflops uns 200
quadrilhões de cálculos por segundo a
plataforma quântica começa com sentida é
tá flops 604 milhões de cálculos por
segundo ciência dos novos materiais têm
germaneno ele é 10 vezes mais rápido que
o silício portanto daqui a pouco você
vai ter uma plataforma de cálculo e vai
bater em 6
de quadrilhões de cálculos por segundo e
você perdido no excel fazendo brincando
de fazer planilha dinâmica não é para
você tá mais lá ok então a quinta
revolução industrial tá chegando forte
com a própria inteligência artificial
onde a gente finalmente entendi que cada
um tem seu espaço as máquinas têm seus
passos e o ser humano tem seu espaço o
problema que cada um tem que trabalhar
no seu quadradinho cada um tem que
trabalhar na sua área né o tempo para
onde a gente tá indo para o fim de tudo
que é de massa não temos nada mais de
massa você vai comer uma comida que só
serve para você e essa comida vai
aparecer um pouco remédio então você não
vai precisar mais tomar remédio a roupa
você vai imprimir na sua casa do jeito
que você quer vamos ter daqui dois anos
internet das coisas que eu cansei do
preto vou lá no celular e muda para roxo
porque a gente vai poder customizar as
roupas da gente através dos verbos
porque a sua roupa seu sapato vai estar
conectado à internet então para quê que
eu posso me preocupar com isso tudo é
feito especificamente cortados sob
medida para você portanto só as duas
coisas junto
é verdade né onde o ser humano é muito
capaz de poder ter análise crítica do
outro lado que a gente tem o poder de
cálculo a gente trabalhando junto com as
máquinas a gente consegue ser
absolutamente disruptivo né portanto a
quinta revolução industrial faz uma
coisa perturbada aquele típico trabalho
das 9 às 17 que eu fico toda vez eu vou
nas empresas eu fico doente com isso
assim porque que a empresa além de tudo
diz quando você tem que ser mais
criativo
e eu tenho que ser criativo só das novas
17 eu não posso a criativo na madrugada
não posso ver mas não posso fazer o
ciclo biológico de criatividade de vinil
da manhã porque eu tenho que fazer isso
as empresas fazem tudo errado elas pedem
currículo para vocês vocês ainda tem um
bom então #ficadica joga fora seu
currículo ele não sai para nada eu
preciso das pessoas mais rápidos olhando
para frente não dando força para o
passado tivemos tempo que não tem
precedentes históricos eu preciso você
quebrando para frente não dando força
para coisa que eu já fui e continuamos
vendo todo mundo né sendo refém de
currículos o que acontece com isso aqui
hoje mas que calculou vamos trabalhar
muito menos vamos ter produtividade
vezes 10 usando quarenta por cento do
nosso tempo
é porque estamos fazendo tarefa de
máquina a base de sessenta por cento mas
o que acontece com sessenta por cento
ósseo
e você tá preparado para o ócio
e o quando você se joga na cama no
sábado a tua cabeça de trabalho já da
cama vagabundo você tem um cachorro para
dar banho você tem que lavar o carro
você tem que fazer supermercado você tem
que ir lá né levar para cortar a grama
tem que arrumar a gaveta qualquer coisa
que deixa constantemente plugado em
tarefas inúteis você tá preparado para o
ócio
oh alô
eu acho que não né ninguém está né
portanto a vida 3.0 é uma vida de ócio
marcada tão simplesmente pela marcação
né é de como o ser humano vai se
modificar numa sociedade 5.0 que é
marcada pelo ócio portanto quem é
responsável por isso mega paradox dessa
área obrigado é justamente né o que a
inteligência artificial no centro por
isso que são grande paradoxo quando a
gente entrega as máquinas que a gente
gostou de fazer não deve sobra tempo
para gente o que que fez a tecnologia
uma coisa terrível ajuntou o viveram
trabalhar eu aprender passa-se uma
instância única o que que tem no centro
propósito você não dividir muito mais se
você tá trabalhando se você não tá se
você tá vivendo ou se você né ele tá
numa outra vaga de viver tudo isso é uma
coisa só que quem tem propósito no
centro fundir essas três coisas o único
havendo que fala uma coisa que é muito
legal que a gente viver nessa sociedade
da grande rapidez e isso é extremamente
esgotante né o luxo do futuro vai ser um
luxo do amor pelo que fazemos e a gente
tô dando um monte de gente que ainda se
for morto uma coisa que nunca quis fazer
só fez porque o pai mandou o pai já
morreu você continua dando resposta para
o seu pai você trabalha com coisa que
você odeia quando você está submetido a
crise passa aquele filme bem na sua
cabeça se o filme b sempre foi seu plano
ar e você a dia
se eu te fazer uma pergunta o que você
tá fazendo da sua vida afinal de contas
não faz o menor sentido que a gente tá
fazendo e as pessoas tão ontem brigando
entre si no mma né todo dia brigando
todo mundo brigando entre si cada coisa
de doido portanto o que que eu preciso
ir aí nadia veu paixão no centro né o
que que eu preciso enxergar eu preciso
ter empresas ambidestros onde eu tenho
que ter criatividade eu nunca perguntei
o preço muito chatas elas não conseguem
ser criativo você tem uma super ideia
você virar meme só se escuta você tirou
o que ontem tá muito doido hoje porque
não pode ter ideia você só pode executar
a tarefa sentido né eu preciso ser um
pouquinho teimoso para correr um
pouquinho de risco para poder enxergar o
mundo de outro ângulo porque tá tudo
viciado tá tudo cheio de coisas né eu
tenho que olhar os profissionais do
futuro que tem quatro coisas que são
inadiáveis eles são apaixonados eles
estudam sozinha porque foi estudar uma
vida inteira super simples né quando a
gente olha profissionais do futuro o que
eles são gente que não se vera gente que
não se assusta estuda sozinho só
se você nunca viu em cansados não
abandona ou nada no meio do caminho tem
proposta do claro alta influência
maturidade influência não é maturidade
autoridade são independentes são os
colaboradores colaboradores turbo
membros da quadrilha porque a quadrilha
não falha no valor convergente ok
portanto tudo aquilo que a gente brinca
de fazer que você já viu no filme de
ficção acaba sendo um filme da realidade
ficcional tudo aquilo que você projetou
como utopia tá virando distopia e tá na
sua vida isso é tão simplesmente para
você acreditar que o futuro chegou e ele
tá no seu nariz você vai ter que reagir
de uma forma diferente portanto a
sociedade cinco pontos era uma sociedade
centrada no ser humano né completamente
voltada para as três lentes que a gente
precisa tudo que a gente vai trabalhar
agora foco é no ser humano
inexoravelmente a federação japonesa de
negócios pau tua pontua né que o futuro
os humanos nem serão requeridos por eles
uma grande capacidade para mudar o mundo
a atividade necessária para materializar
suas idéias né portanto a sociedade o
5.0 por causa do ócio e altíssima
tecnologia vai ser a sociedade da
imaginação temos que resgatar
urgentemente nossa capacidade de fazer
ficção portanto quando a gente olha tudo
aquilo que é o human centered design é
trabalho do futuro tudo que vai ser
feito no futuro terá o ser humano como
centro né o que que da requerida
sobrepressão de você por favor volta a
fazer infecção é tudo que a gente
precisa porque você ficou chato porque
você acreditou que a vida é aquilo que
você ressignificar dela vamos trabalhar
um pouquinho para gente trazer a ficção
como a gente nunca viu e eu me despeço
de você do jeito mais um ano que eu
consigo ser que a desejar para você que
você seja de verdade muito feliz né que
você tem esse desgraçado que você tá
fazendo da sua vida e que você tenha né
saúde e paz obrigado por